les cinq experts de l'onu la haute
commissaire aux droits de l'homme de
l'onu la commission européenne le
conseil de l'europe
la défenseure de trois enfants sont tous
dits tout dit vous prônez le mauvais
chemin du gouvernement arrêtée avec lui
d'attaquer les libertés fondamentales
[Musique]
des journalistes ont été interpellés des
avocats des personnes de notre
coordination ont été interpellés
pêle-mêle et sont tous ressortis sans
doute poursuite puisque rodez rien leur
reprocher sinon d'avoir été sur la sur
le chemin des sacs
de police y décider quand elle servait
quand elles qui paient des
manifestations je veux dire c'est une
démonstration par l'absurde de
l'inefficacité dangereuse du préfet de
police
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]